This edition of Scout Mash Podcast is brought to you by folks at Conahoe Creek Outfitters.
They know camping and they know scouts. They are scouts
And they know how to get your rig here at Greenprices for all your camping adventures.
So go visit them at conahoecreakcom.
That's C-O-N-O-H-O-Creakcom.
And now to your Scout Master.
You know, whoever said where there's smoke there's fire
likely had never gone camping with my scouts.
Hey, this is podcast number 172..
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green.
The mailbag is just absolutely jam-packed. So let's get right to it, shall we?
Here's the messages that you've sent me, and if you're listening and you'd like to get in touch,
you can email me at Clark C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
Mike Arliss wrote in and he said: I enjoy reading your blog. Thanks, Mike.
Thanks, Mike. Thanks for getting in touch.
Keith Palki is with Troop 11 in Juneau, Alaska,
And he said: Clark, I really like your infographics but I don't have access to a good color printer.
I'd like to have them for troop meetings. Are they available for purchase anywhere?
No, Keith, unfortunately they're not. There's got to be a copy center or something there
with a decent color printer, and you can also always just print them out in black and white.
You can do that.
Greg Gotcher is Cubmaster with Troop 372 in Waterford, Wisconsin,
And he wrote in to say I came across your site a few weeks ago
and I've downloaded all the podcasts onto my mobile device
and have listened to all my trips to and from work. Just really love them.
Thanks, Greg, Glad to hear you're listening. I'm glad you're enjoying things.
I think we accompany a lot of people to and from work,
So if you're headed in the morning or headed home in the afternoon,
I hope you have a good day or had a good day. How about that?
Tracy Lucas is with Scout Troop 2379 in Canyon Country, California,
And she wrote in to say this: you've been our partner on this long and winding journey,
So I thought I'd update you just a little bit.
Over the past several years, even before my husband Dave became our scout master,
our troop endured kind of a split.
Some parents laughed because they didn't like the way scouting was going in our troop
And we did lose a couple of leaders who were more interested in their own personal scouting experience
than in serving the boys.
At last year's summer camp we only had nine scouts go,
but we had a vision and faith in the program to watch these scouts go to camp
and have their own experience and figure things out on their own
Soon. after that we welcomed two new families through scouts talking to their friends,
And then this spring we had five weeblos and their parents crossover from Cub Scouts.
Our new guys are having fun and they've invited their friends as well.
This year we'll have 17 scouts go to camp and five adults will be accompanying them.
Thank you for being a source of encouragement, advice
and for being our Monday morning inspiration. before the challenge of a Tuesday night meeting,
A scouting family that we have known for many years chose to join our troop. this week,
When they visited the troop, their two sons found the scouts were planning meetings
and future trips and setting advancement goals,
something that had been missing from their scouting experience.
When one mentioned something he wanted to do, all of our scouts tried to work it into the calendar.
He was shocked both at the willingness of the Patrol Leaders Council to do this
and that it could even happen in the first place.
You're right. When the scouts own the program, they find it much more exciting and interesting.
I just thought I'd let you know and to say thanks and also to encourage everyone listening
that it may take time, sometimes years, as it did in our case-
but it's worth it when we get to watch the scouts do for themselves.
Well, thanks so much, Tracy.
We've emailed back and forth a few times.
I sure appreciate your words of support and thanks
and your encouragement to your fellow scouters.
You know, sometimes it takes a long time to make things happen,
but after a while it does pay off.
Roger Eakins is in Tule, Utah,
and he said: I'm a scribe on a wood badge course
and I'd love to include your 15 thoughts for Scout Leaders Infographic in the Gazette.
Of course I'd give you credit to you in your blog.
Please let me know if this is okay.
Absolutely, Roger. Feel free to use it.
I appreciate it when people do
and everything we produce is to advance scouting
and it's freely offered
Anything that we have- the podcasts, the videos,
any of the posts, the infographics, anything.
feel free to use them however you like,
and all's we ask is that you let people know where you found them.
If you keep up with scouting online,
you probably know who Frank Maynard is.
Frank Maynard is a longtime committee chairman
who blogs at bobwhiteblathercom
and he wrote in to say this:
your advice in podcast number 171,
that was our last podcast folks
for Jeff and Oxnard,
who thought his troop may have too much adult involvement
on scout campouts was great.
New parents do tend to get confused
and the notion that scout camping
is anything like the parent and son camping
they did in Cub Scouts
really kind of needs to be erased as soon as possible.
Most parents do relate well
to the concept of sports team organization and dynamics.
It's something they can understand.
There is a difference, though,
in that coaches in sports teams
usually have a lot more control over what happens.
They run the drills, they call the place,
select players and things like that.
and in scouting and a scout master's job
is really quite different.
He helps those processes
but he's only mentoring the team captain
or the senior patrol leader
and he's not really directly involved
in calling the shots while the game is being played.
It's kind of difficult for an adult scout leader,
especially one with coaching experience,
to realize and embrace the difference
between sports and scouting. in that regard,
Of course, training is important,
and boy scout leader fast start training
and the scout master specific training
gives everyone a better understanding
of scouting as a whole,
The differences between Cub Scouts
and Boy Scouts and the role of adults in a troop.
And once we're trained
we've got to agree to follow the program.
We can't go through training
and later decide it just won't work that way
and invent some alternate reality form
of scouting for ourselves.
You're exactly right, Frank.
Thanks for your words of encouragement there.
and you know folks get over
and look at bobwhiteblathercom.
Go read what Frank has to say.
He's spot on and he has some wonderful
advice for scouters.
Dave Klein wrote in to say this:
I'm standing in Costco with
a giant smile and teary eyes
listening to your last podcast
and your piece about Mother's Day.
Thanks, Dave, I'm glad you enjoyed that.
Ray Britton is a scout master
with Troop 42
and he's a scout master.
and he's a scout master
and he's a scout master with Troop 42
in Oak Ridge, Tennessee.
He says after years I still love
your podcast. I discovered it near the
beginning and look forward to every installment.
That is something I can say
about few podcast, TV shows
or magazines. Thanks for all you do
for us scouters who are kind
of lost in the wilderness out there.
Count me as a scout master
CG disciple. Keep up the
outstanding work. Enjoyed the scout
circle presentation last night
and I am tempted to join you in
Switzerland next year. Thanks, Ray,
I really appreciate
your words of encouragement there.
Scout Circle is a monthly
live presentation
we've been doing this year and it's
coming along. It's working pretty good.
Try to do a live monthly
presentation online
and you'll discover that it's
not quite so easy as it sounds, But anyway,
over at scoutcircleorg
you can see the
presentation that Arlan Ward
and I recorded last night.
I was actually the
guest this time
talking about Kondersteg International
Scout Center,
the trip that our troop took over there
in 2011
and the trip that we are planning
for 2014.. If you're listening
and you would like to have a really
wonderful experience for your scouts,
go check out last night's
presentation on scoutcircleorg.
you can learn a little something about
Kondersteg International Scout Center
and how we arrange our trips and everything like that,
and hopefully it will encourage you
to take a look into making such a trip
for your troop or your venture crew.
Bob Case
is with troop 61
in Corning, New York, and he said:
I want to say thank you, Clark, for
reading my article on bullying last week
and thank you, Bob, for offering it.
as everybody knows, this is
a constant, ongoing concern for
all of us something we want to watch for.
we want to create a culture in
scouting that is bully free.
Once again, thanks, Bob,
for your contribution to that.
Sherry writes another
interesting blog that I just discovered this week.
it's
cubscoutideascom.
cubscoutideas- all one word
dot com, Sherry said.
you made me tear up a little bit when I read your piece
about Scout Mother's Day.
I have two Cub Scouts
who just finished his Tiger year
and one who just finished Weeblos one.
my husband and I have been den leader
since the oldest started in Cub Scouts.
when I think that this is his last year
until he's a Boy Scout,
it's very bittersweet.
he says he wants to earn his Eagle rank
and I hope he does. then I'll be the mom
fumbling around with pins and wiping tears away.
I just discovered your site
and I'm anxious to read more of your posts,
thanks. thank you so much, Sherry.
I'm glad you enjoyed that.
it's great to be involved in Scouting
and I really appreciate
the information that you've put out there
for Cub Scout leaders
at cubscoutideascom.
and thanks for being in touch.
check out our YouTube channel. last week
we posted a video review
of the Brunton Restore
Solar Battery Charger,
which is, you know,
10 years ago was a product
that probably didn't exist.
I got one
from
our sponsors
and I got a chance to kick the tires
and use it some.
and if you're interested in
a device that you can carry with you
and will charge your mobile devices
while you're out camping or traveling,
take a look at that video
and make sure to check out our YouTube channel.
it's scoutmastercg over on YouTube.
so this podcast is
being recorded
on May
20, 2013,
and it has been
my habit
on the blog and in podcasts
to stay away from debatable questions
of religion
and politics and things like that,
but unless you've been
living under a rock for these past few months,
you are aware
the Boy Scouts of America,
our Scouting organization,
has undertaken
a lengthy
and thorough examination
of its membership standards.
after this review,
our national executive board
has drafted a membership
standards resolution
that will be voted on on Thursday,
May 23, at the
BSA annual meeting.
there's approximately 1400
voting members representing
265 local councils
nationwide,
and they're going to vote on a resolution
that, in short,
removes the stipulation
that youth members
can be excluded from membership in the BSA
based solely
on their sexual orientation.
in this podcast, we're going to spend
a little bit of time
discussing this issue
and sharing with you
some of the information that the BSA
has published
for the voting members.
the reason that I am choosing to discuss this now
is that I think
that this is a historic moment
in the history of the BSA.
now, when I broach this subject
on the blog or on the podcast,
it is clear
everyone listening- and everyone reading
is not necessarily
going to be in agreement
with my opinions
or with the opinions of
our national executive committee.
the BSA has prepared
a voting member information packet
that's available as a pdf file.
if you'll go to
scoutmastercgcom,
you'll find the post
that I'm referring to and I'll make sure
to link it to this podcast
so that you can go and read that packet
yourself if you like,
and it describes the voting process
and includes the findings of the membership
standards review.
now, in addition to that
membership information packet,
our national president, Wayne Perry,
and a member of the national executive committee,
Nathan Rosenberg,
and our chief scout executive,
Wayne Brock,
hosted an in-depth discussion
of the BSA's membership standards
resolution
back at the end of April
and they recorded this discussion
and it is available for viewing.
you'll find that video at
scoutmastercgcom.
we're all aware that this membership
standards review is a historic effort
on the part of the BSA.
no matter where you come down on this,
you can certainly say
thank you to the people who put their
hearts and minds and thousands
of volunteer hours into this
process in an honest
desire to do their best for our scouts.
we all owe them our appreciation.
the presentation
that I'm speaking of- the video presentation-
is a long one- it lasts about an
hour- but it's worth your time.
what I found particularly interesting
was a narrative of what happened at the
meeting of the committee assembled
to draft the membership resolution,
and this was related
by our national executive
committee vice president for human resources.
his name is Lyle Knight.
he said that, whatever your
personal opinion might be,
someone who was working on
this resolution
shared your opinion.
if you'll go and listen to that video
and listen to our national leaders,
you're soon going to understand.
we're going to be choosing one of two
paths: we're going to choose to change
our membership standards or we're going to choose
to maintain them as they are right now.
there's a slide that was shared on the video
that I've been talking about
that kind of describes what happens
if we change
and what happens if we don't change.
basically, what happens if
the membership policy changes
is it's projected
we're going to experience an initial
decline in membership
of around 15%
in both youth and adult members.
we're going to probably
experience a significant financial loss
nationally
and we'll possibly lose
a significant number of chartered partners.
that's a very sobering reality,
isn't it, and I know that it's causing us
a lot of angst
and sadness
and distress.
as sobering as the projected results
changing the membership policy is,
the projected results of
not changing it
is probably even more dire.
the BSA has lost
nearly 30%
of our membership over the past
dozen or so years.
I'm sure that there are many reasons for that.
I know personally,
at least in our council.
we can attribute
a lot of this membership stagnation
and this loss of membership
to the current policy.
that's not going to be true
in every part of the country and I understand that.
but I can tell you from my own experience
and the reactions that we get
when we're recruiting for Cub Scouts
that this policy
is a barrier to participation
for a number of people
that we talk to.
so not changing this membership policy
means that we're probably
going to continue to see this
loss of membership
and see it accelerate.
we're going to see a continued erosion
of financial support
and, I think,
an accelerated marginalization
of the BSA.
so on the one hand, we know that
there's an immediate loss
and an immediate result from changing
the policy,
but the long-term results of not changing it
are even worse
than the immediate results
of changing it.
but it's still enough to think that
if we change this membership policy
it will immediately open the floodgates
and result in a significant increase
in membership.
perhaps the best case scenario
is that our rate of loss
slows down.
perhaps we'll see that loss level out
and we may see a modest increase
over the next several years.
I do agree with what
our national executive board
has projected:
the BSA is going to be
a significantly smaller
and significantly less relevant
organization to the vast majority
of American families in years to come.
so I do join
the members of our national executive board
in calling on
support for the resolution
and, beyond that,
a spirit of cooperation.
no matter what happens this Thursday,
we're going to see some of
our valuable adult volunteers
and chartering organizations
decide that they can no longer
identify themselves with the BSA.
that is tragic
and it's unfortunate.
I can understand the depth of emotion
involved in that kind of decision
and I've had discussions
via email with people
who are really feeling this
and are really having an internal
struggle with it.
despite all the wrangling and all the discussion
and all the assumptions
that our national leadership,
over and over again
in their deliberations on this,
has emphasized, their actions
are in response to
one single concern:
what is the best course of action
for our scouts?
I believe they're earnestly trying to provide
the best answer that they can.
I believe that's a question
that all of us have to answer:
how do we best serve
our scouts
whenever? to answer that question
to the best of my ability.
any responsible volunteer
is endeavoring to answer that question
to the best of their ability.
on this particular issue,
we'll reach different conclusions,
but we ought to be able to find a way forward
that really is the best solution
for all of the scouts
we're serving now
and all of the scouts that we can
potentially serve in the future.
looking at the history of
scouting and
reading
what our founder,
Robert Baden-Powell, had to say
about it can help us
look forward a bit.
after scouting was founded,
it quickly spread around the world,
just spontaneously.
Baden-Powell wrote this about
those years:
he said scouting was not a year old
before other countries had formed
their own branches.
outside training has spread to
42 different countries
around the world
and has proved its potentiality
as a factor in world peace.
now, at that time,
some urged Baden-Powell
that this spontaneous growth
was probably not a great idea.
you need to stop and control this
and patent your idea
so that other people in other countries
can't just pick it up
and start using it.
it's an exclusive movement
and it's going to become diluted and diminished
when people in other countries start using it.
you should have some control over that.
they may not get it right.
it's too unstable and too uncertain
just to let it go.
I think Baden-Powell sensed that
this spontaneous growth
of scouting was not really dangerous
and it didn't threaten to dilute
scouting and make it something that
he didn't intend it to be.
I think that he saw that this
spontaneity and the diversity that resulted from it
would in fact
become one of the greatest and strongest
things about scouting.
I think his vision evolved.
he was a military man
and he incorporated a lot of militaristic
ideas into scouting.
as scouting started to spread through the world,
he saw it
as a vehicle for world peace.
Baden-Powell would call
the first international scout gathering
in 1920
the first reunion of
the world's boyhood in the aftermath
of World War I.
after 10 days of camping
and working together in Olympia, London,
the scouts of more than 20 nations
met with Baden-Powell and they asked him
to make this appeal.
at the end of what would become known
as the first world jamboree,
he said this:
brother scouts, I ask you
to make a solemn choice.
differences exist between
people of the world in thought and temperament.
this jamboree has taught us
that, with mutual give and take,
under a common ideal,
sympathy and harmony are established.
if it be your will, therefore,
let us endeavor
to develop amongst our boys
such comradeship, through the
world wide scout spirit
of brotherhood, that peace
and good will may henceforth
reign among men.
are you willing to join me
in this high enterprise?
and the scouts that
heard this appeal responded
overwhelmingly
yes, we will.
in writing about this momentous occasion,
Baden-Powell quoted the Bengali poet
Rabindranath Tagore,
who wrote:
it's through brotherhood
and not through organization that the world
should be ordered. we are citizens
of the kingdom of ideas.
there will be men large enough
to see the human race as a whole
and who understand that the good
of the community
as a family does exist.
Baden-Powell added to this,
if we reflect that
we are all members of the human family
and we're only here on this earth
for a short span of life,
we realize that the petty differences
and fighting for little
selfish ends are out of
place in the creator's scheme.
Tagore's thought and
Baden-Powell's word
described the promise of scouting very simply:
we can all get along
with each other if we try.
some scouts in a patrol may want one thing
for dinner while they're camping and someone
another thing. what do they do? they discuss
and they debate and they arrive at a decision.
that really
kind of seemingly insignificant decision
made by a bunch of boys
is something that is going to echo
throughout their lives
and throughout the world, with the message:
we can get along with each other
if we try,
scouting spread spontaneously.
and only then was it
clothed in the garments of tradition
and policy and rules and regulations.
if organizations grow too inflexible
and arthritic to suit
the vitality
of the ideas that created them,
they have to renew themselves,
they have to change
or they're going to crumble
and fall. now, naturally,
not everybody is
invigorated and energized by change.
there are those of us,
in every successive generation
in human history,
who, on reaching a certain age, think that the world
has become worse somehow. but I think
really. I think our best days are ahead.
I wouldn't exchange the time
that we're living in, with all its
problems and difficulties,
for any era in the past.
I don't think there's any perfect place
for us to return to in the past
and I don't think there's any ideal future ahead.
I think what we have
is we have now,
and I think that we're called on to be leaders
right now.
the scouting idea grows despite us.
we can't hold it back,
no matter how hard we try.
in these past few months, we've all been caught up
in working to define the future
of the Boy Scouts
of America.
we've argued, we've debated,
we've listened and talked
and now a decision is going to be made.
the decision is
just a start.
whatever is decided,
you know some of us are going to disagree
and some of us may leave.
change and innovation
are uncertain and dynamic
and unpredictable elements.
they challenge us, they upset us,
but we ought to welcome the idea
of change and we ought to work hard
to see what's next.
the scouting idea will continue on
to change the world one
scout at a time.
Baden Powell's appeal
nearly a century ago
at that first world jamboree
is still alive to us today.
let us therefore endeavor
to develop amongst our scouts
such comradeship,
through the worldwide scout
spirit of brotherhood,
that peace and goodwill
can henceforth reign among men.
are you willing to join
this high enterprise?
we can all get along if we try.
we can all make this work,
wherever we end up at the end of this week,
let's resolve this,
that we're going to roll up our sleeves
and we're going to endeavor to work together
in the best way possible
to serve our scouts,
because that's the point of all of this, isn't it?
we can all get along
if we try
music.
thanks once again for listening
to this edition of the scout master podcast,
and I appreciate your patience
and your forbearance with the subject matter-
something divisive,
as this is always difficult to discuss
and I get a lot of emails
and I get a lot of comments
from both ends of the spectrum.
I appreciate respectful comments
from either,
and so do
do get in touch.
you can email me at
clarkclarke
at
scoutmastercgcom.
you can read the scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and when you do, you can subscribe
for more updates by email.
you can also subscribe to the scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes.
you can access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher smart radio,
and you can find out how to do that at stitchercom,
and you can experience the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
yep,
there's scoutmaster blog on facebook,
there's scoutmastercg
on twitter
and there's a scoutmastercg circle.
we're on Pinterest, we're on LinkedIn
and we've got a new YouTube channel
that I mentioned in the podcast.
I'll remind you. you can email me.
that's right. zoom into the 90s.
it's clarkclarke
at scoutmastercgcom.
naturally, the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
it's just me.
I'm talking into a microphone, trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
speaking of fun, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and group camping.
my thank you, sir,
until next time.